have you ever said no when offered pizza
have you ever texted lol and not
actually laughed out loud
do you take bites of other people's food
without asking do you post your workouts
to Facebook
do you have tag when you text do you put
empty milk cartons back in the fridge do
you abruptly stop on sidewalks or in
doorways to look at your phone do you
consider yourself a pickup artist have
you ever turned down ice cream when
you're talking to your dog do you refer
to yourself as mommy do you keep a trash
can in your bathroom do you frequently
ask questions about the movie you're
currently watching what piece do you
choose in monopoly Neapolitan ice cream
what flavor do you meet first when you
finish a roll of toilet paper do you
replace it immediately or just put a new
roll on top do you ever spit on the
street do you leave the door open when
peeing when you're sharing ice cream do
you intentionally mine out the little
pieces of chocolate leaving the vanilla
for somebody else
only selfies do you take in a day what's
your favorite emoji
do you eat voicemails does your dog have
a wardrobe do you too loudly its fries
or salad even questions